Hãy sửp bên chuyện, tận động tiếp tục trường lực lượng công an, bứng tối tưởng trong nhóm tiếp dịch tại sản đã ra đầu thú.
Cình này người tắm đến người mười chính tháng 3 năm 2020, các quan cạnh sát điều tra công an thành phố
bình thư đã ra biết định tạm giữ hình sự ba đối tưởng của mình.
Một, Mê Hàng Vũ, trên năm 2020, tính chăm tắm người ba, cùng thú tại sải châu sông, tính ăn ra.
2 hành hoặc sáng, trên năm 2020, cùng thú tại phù Mỹ thử, tính ăn ra.
3 hành hoặc sáng, trên năm 2020, cùng thú tại phù Mỹ thử, tính ăn ra.
Vình bối tưởng dương trình mẹ hành, trên năm 2020, cùng thú tại phù Mỹ thử, tính ăn ra.
Đăng người còn giữ tà mù sấu tháng 4, nền tơ quan đều tra sân xét thương tạm giữ hình sự.
1. Mến tưởng nêu xong đều là đối tưởng thảo tình húng trên lắm, sau đẩy về chắc người đi hay.
1. Tại phù quan tương an, các bối tưởng đều trường dựng tròng hộ hành phí phản tội.
1. Tình phủ trị kêu phòng tình xác hình sử tôn manh thành phố bình thư tiếp tục bù gà.
1. Tại sách mở tổng, phía bắt các bối cường còn lại, trong giống bối trị phía phay sáng.